Alo ạ
anh alo chào các bạn
hình trật tự nhiên Tự vẫn à bây giờ tối
hiu buồn cười à
xem các bạn cái này ờ cha không bị ăn
bản quyền đâu Chắc thế
ý em nhỉ
ở phần trước cho xem có ăn nhỉ bây giờ
không Ờ và có thể cách nói chuyện cái ý
tưởng này khá hay cho mình không xem à
Còn nếu mà ông ấy ông nhờ kỹ hôm trước
thì cuối buổi thôi tự nhiên bị đau bụng
thì
ra nó còn đây rất bình thường cho rồi
đúng là nó tí nghị thật nha nó ra là
bình thường tôi sẽ thử cho người không
xem và khi mà một cái vấn đề tế nhị
nhưng mà họ nói theo kiểu dạng và góc
nhìn khác một cách phấn vở hơn thì mọi
người sẽ thấy nó bình thường hơn thế nào
để gửi cho mẹ em thử xem nhé
à à các
một thứ gì đó đang di chuyển đổi ra
trong bụng của bạn Nó có thể là dấu hiệu
của việc đứa con của bạn sắp chào đời và
bạn cần phải đến bệnh viện ngay lập tức
Tuy nhiên nếu như bạn chưa có chồng hoặc
đang có vòi thì xin chúc mừng bạn đang
muốn đi có một điều khá lạ là trong số
vô vàn những câu chuyện được Nói ra hàng
ngày thì chuyện đi là một trong số ít
nhất xuyên không được nói ra một cách
thoải mái Mặc dù giống như việc ăn và
việc ngủ thì đi là một việc mà ai trên
đời này cũng làm bạn làm bố mẹ bạn cũng
làm hàng xóm bạn cũng làm và chắc chắn
các vlogger và YouTube ờ yêu thích của
bạn cũng và có thể là đang làm chính xác
ra thì nói về chuẩn bị còn dễ đồng cảm
hơn là nói về chuyện yêu bởi vì không
phải ai cũng đã và đang được yêu nhưng
gần như ai cũng biết cảm giác khi đặt
Mông xuống một cái bệ ngồi lại phóng
hoặc là ướt hoặc là ấm như có ai và đàn
ông lên đấy Ừ thì ai cũng biết là cái
chủ đề này tương đối ạ Nhưng bạn nên
biết rằng có bao nhiêu thứ bao gồm cả
bàn phím máy tính và mặt điện thoại của
bạn còn bẩn hơn gấp nhiều lần so với bồn
cầu hơn nữa việc mất vệ sinh cũng có vẻ
không đủ để ngăn bạn mang đủ các thứ
sách báo điện thoại máy móc vô cùng mặc
dù rõ ràng là sau khi xong việc thì bạn
chỉ rửa tay chứ không rửa mấy thứ đấy Ừ
thì ngồi một chỗ mà không làm gì rất là
chán mà mất vệ sinh một tí nhưng để làm
việc có ích thì đỡ hơn là ngồi không và
hít thở Tuy nhiên nếu như bạn dành cho
thời gian đấy để nghĩ ngợi về cái việc
mà bạn đang làm một chút thì bạn sẽ thấy
rằng được đi cũng có rất nhiều điều thú
vị ví dụ như khi viết chữ y Bạn có thể
viết xuôi viết ngược thế nào thì vẫn cứ
ra là chữ y bạn có thể cắt chia theo
hướng nào thì vẫn thấy đối xứng hai bản
thân sẽ đi cũng có một cái gì đấy rất dễ
thương theo kiểu trẻ con mới đẻ tức là
nhỏ gọn xinh xắn Tuy có hơi bốc mùi toàn
thân trước khi đọc lên cũng không quá
mức thô thiển nhưng các từ cùng nghĩa mà
lại tương đối dễ nghe nói thật là kể cả
nếu bạn có thai chữ đi cho Anh giao tiếp
hàng ngày thì nghe vẫn lễ phép như bình
thường không như thế được đi còn có tính
công bằng bình đẳng rất cao khác với họ
hàng của nó là việc đi Tài vốn phân biệt
giới tính rất rõ ràng đường đi hoàn toàn
bình đẳng về mặt giới tính ngoài ra việc
đi còn bình đẳng cả về mặt xã hội tất cả
mọi người trên thế giới kể cả những nhân
vật tiếng tăm nhất kể cả những nhân vật
đáng sợ nhất kể cả các chàng trai cô gái
hoàn hảo nhất mà bạn từng thấy tất cả
đều đã từng ít nhất một lần bị tiêu chảy
Ngoài ra thì nếu như bạn đã thân y ở chỗ
công cộng thì bạn cũng biết rằng đây là
nơi tính cách thể hiện rất rõ rệt có
những người thì khá tự tin và ồn ào náo
nhiệt có những người lại chỉ âm thầm
trong cùng nhầm có cả những người phải
chờ đến khi không có ai mà dám hành sự
vì sợ bị đánh giá bởi những người mới
chị thấy chân của mình nếu bạn đã từng
đi làm thì bạn cũng sẽ thấy rằng đi ở cơ
quan giúp cho mọi công việc trở nên hấp
dẫn hơn bởi vì nó cũng giống như là việc
người ta trả tiền cho bạn để bạn đi hoặc
là có những việc mà bạn có thể làm trong
khi y nhưng lại không thấy trong cho ví
dụ bạn có thể đọc sách trong toilet
nhưng lại không thể ý trong thư viện bạn
có thể ngồi hát trong toilet nhưng lại
không thể đi khi đang trên sân khấu bạn
có thể xem Vlog trong toilet Nhưng có vẻ
là chưa có ai vừa Quay vlog vừa ý cả
thật ra thì với việc với lốc chỉ quay
được nửa trên thì làm sao có thể chắc
chắn rằng nửa còn lại của Vinpearl đang
không ngồi trên toilet chứ Rồi lại có
những việc ví dụ nhưng về ngủ thì nhảy
ngược lại tức là bạn không thể ngủ trong
khi đang ít nhưng lại có thể đi trên
giường sau đó thì lại có những việc ví
dụ như là ăn thì bạn lại không thể làm
được cả hai chiều Tức là không thể vừa
ăn với được ngoài ra cũng giống như khi
tắm hoặc khi chạy bộ thì không gian yên
tĩnh Khi ngồi trong toilet vô cùng phù
hợp cho mọi thứ tuôn trào trong đó có ý
tưởng một số ý tưởng thì ra rất dễ dàng
một số lại cần tìm giàu một số ý tưởng
thì ra một cách nhỏ giọt một số lại ra
mãi chưa thấy hết một số ý tưởng sau khi
ra hết thì hết sức gọn gàng không cần
chỉnh sửa nhiều một số thì lại vô cùng
thùng giấy ở suối tưởng thì hết sức tiện
dụng nhưng đa số ý tưởng thì giống như
câu nói phổ biến như cứt Vì thế nên bạn
cũng nên biết ý tưởng nào có thể tận
dụng được và ý tưởng nào thì lên xả nước
thật sự thì với một cái chủ đề như thế
này thì cũng tương đối khó để giúp ra
một cái bài học hay thông điệp sâu sắc
gì thế nên để kết lại thì xin tạm dừng
một phần khách sau bạn có biết vì sao
bồn cầu lại có nắp không đó là vì nếu
bạn giọt nước mà không đậy nắp thì sẽ có
hàng triệu các thể loại vi khuẩn và các
chất bẩn lý thì vừa nằm trong một cầu
của bạn bay lên theo hơi nước và bám vào
tất cả những thứ trong nhà vệ sinh bao
gồm cả bàn chải mà bạn sẽ đưa vào miệng
cái phân phát từ sự thật thú vị cuối
Thực ra tôi biết lâu rồi mà tổn thường
xuyên làm
chắc là đấy là tôi biết thôi chứ không
biết mấy ông thì có biết hay không
Ok thì đấy một vấn đề mà tịch từ các
hành vi các bạn thì giống như trong
video có đây cập khá tế nhị nhưng mà nó
lại một cái sẽ bình đảo mà giữ bình
thường có rất nhiều cái tới nghị
một chậu dục kể cả về 18 + hay Vân rất
nhiều cái
khi chúng ta được à
Anh ơi khi dùng ra lại hơi ngại nhắc đến
nó rồi Nó là một cái nhu cầu tôi thể khá
bình thường mà chúng ta lại Đôi khi coi
những cái mà thời sự ở những cái nó hơi
bị sai lệch thì mình lại cho nó là tế
nhị đấy à không không không có bị sai
lầm thì mình cho bình thường chứ sao
mình thản nhiên nói về nó như thật ý
nghĩa là là bây giờ thời đại vừa nó đang
hơi bị đảo lộn hơi bị cơ bị loạn
tiếp theo cũng trước ở tôi tranh thủ
ngồi lên Lướt đi thắp vẫn khuyên mày ông
ở thỉnh thoảng kiểu mình nói chung một
trang này ở trang
chẳng dân công nghệ thông tin mà đóng
bạn thì
cụ thể chính xác và trang của dân lập
trình bọn mình nên thành ra là
ở chỗ lên để nó xem theo dõi cái ví dụ
như này xem có cái gì hay hay về mà tham
khảo
à à
vợ
chồng như thế này thì
Ừ thì thôi là ở trên này mấy ông theo
dõi rồi theo dõi đúng người rồi Văn thì
sẽ có thêm rất nhiều thứ để mà đáng để
mà học hỏi giống như là tôi hôm trước
tôi vừa xem thêm liệt kê đồng một khá
nhiều cái nữa như này chẳng hạn ví dụ
nha cả hai cực cái tôi từng nói qua cho
mấy ông về cái tác dụng của csrf rồi Nó
là một cái đoạn for được tạo ra ngẫu
nhiên để cho boss nó không giả danh được
iPhone Đấy ví dụ ví dụ Giả sử là cái
form của ông
trong ví dụ Giả sử cái phom của ông sẽ
chỉ cần điền username email đấy email và
mật khẩu
password sau đó thì ngược sẽ mấy thứ lọc
post nói chuyện đến Oro là ví dụ là kiểu
size CF chẳng hạn như thế này xong rồi
một ông hacker người thích cách tạo Hằng
triệu tài khoản ảo ở trên trang của ông
Thế cho nó cẩu phái thì nó sẽ spam liên
tục vào cái Google này với mấy cái nội
dung này không ạ thì ông sẽ lưu lại toàn
bộ cái đấy vào trong nước bây không đúng
chứ Thế thì thì chết kết hợp với việc là
đấy chỉ là một ví dụ thôi Thế này là cái
này thường hay mình sẽ kết hợp trên cả
các cha không ạ gặp cha để phân biệt
post Nếu mà còn thêm một cái nữa
ạ Bây giờ giả sử là là tương tự như này
nó không phải là cái bài toán kiểu chỉ
đơn giản là cộng 30 này ta sử loa kiểu
đấy thì hồi trước tôi có đề cập ví dụ là
hồi trước chính hacker từng là bụng đấy
Thật đó là sự là ví dụ khi mong chuyển
tiền qua tập qua app hay tài khoản ngân
hàng khác thì ông sẽ thường ai điền số
tài khoản ngân hàng không ạ sau đó thì
cậu loại Ngân hàng nào đúng ạ Bạn ngân
hàng đấy Sau đó thì
bản thân bản thân nó vẫn còn mấy thấp
bóp thôi đúng không ạ Và Giả sử á Đúng
rồi số tiền nữa số tiền số Hà Nội dung
đúng chứ
nội dung này suoer giả sử là chuyển tiền
hãy hiểu ngay đấy thì
Ừ nếu mà chỉ đơn giản trong Karma chỉ có
nhân này nội dung như này thôi và đương
nhiên là phải đăng nhập với tư cách của
ông rồi nhưng mà giọt sự là ông vẫn đang
đăng nhập tài khoản của ông chắc chắn
rồi ở ở trên máy của ông hoặc trên trên
đại loại là trên máy của ông đúng không
sau đó thì có một hacker nó gửi cho ông
một cái một cái kiểu đường link
à à Một cái đường link Xong rồi ông nick
vào đấy nhưng lên đây nó có thể gọi đến
cái gọi đến cái kiểu cái ua lâu này kèm
theo mấy cái mới hốt kiểu ngay đấy chẳng
hạn thế nó có như ông tự động tự động
chuyển tiền hồi đấy à Có cái vụ đấy Tôi
không biết gì mà còn không Nhưng nói
chung là từ cái vụ đấy nó mới sinh ra
cái vụ là xét
nó kiểu Thế nó sinh ra một cái đoạn Mã
ngẫu nhiên phải kèm theo cái đoạn này
thì mới sắp được cái form này phòng hợp
lệ chứ nếu mà chỉ có mỗi lần này nội
dung thôi kèm theo là ông Nam đăng nhập
mà ông vẫn có thể thao tác được thì rất
dễ cầu a hacker có thể kiểu gửi cho anh
cái đường link hay giả danh tài khoản
của ông để mới lisp em cái gì Vân
cô gái trẻ một trong số những cái mà
kiểu à
vợ chồng hát khủng và tương tự thằng này
cũng thế hài cốm cái còn hay hơn Hi Ờ
anh cũng có một cách Tam khác đó là ở có
vài cái tiện ích là tự động điền form
chỉ có vài cái tiện ích ở trên
chôm hoặc các tự mình cũng được sẽ tự
động điền form đầy đủ tất cả những cái
input có thể đôi khi ở mấy cái chữ vô
nghĩa cũng được nhưng gần như nó người
spam với phom đấy Xong rồi Star đấy lại
tự động chạy giả lập trình duyệt ngồi
Star
rất nhiều phom cái thử thử thì nên là nó
một khái niệm cái Pocket này ra đời nó
ra nó kiểu bị ngược lại lại cái xe vừa
nãy đó là sẽ rất là bắt buộc trong form
phải có cái phải phải điền vào cái đấy
phải có cái đấy và điền ở đấy thì for
mới hợp lệ đúng không ạ con cái này
Ngược lại trong form phải có cái này có
cái Honey Pot này nhưng for này bắt buộc
phải để chống thì nọ à Kể cái input này
bắt buộc phải lấy trống thì mới hợp lệ
còn nếu mà và đương nghe cái input này
sẽ lại nút hai là hai Đừng nghĩ em mặc
định với người dùng người dùng sẽ không
ngờ nhìn thấy cái i Ừ cái đấy nè Không
sợ người dùng điện ngầm Nhưng mà nếu mà
mình chạy bằng mình nếu mà chạy vào cốt
bằng ra suýt hay chạy bằng bóp thì mà
mình để cho boss tự động Điền tất cả các
input có thể trong cái form đúng ngoại
thì sẽ điền nhầm vào trong cái trong đến
bút này và một khi Điền nằm ở trong cái
bút Này thì
Ừ thì nó sẽ chuyển trả nó không nhận
thôi Bởi vì cái này nó gần như à cái nó
bắt buộc phải để trống không thấy nó sẽ
báo lỗi đơn giản thế thôi nghĩa nó ngược
lại với sẽ rồi ép rồi nãy nhờ cùng cơ
chế vẫn là để chặn boss và chặn kiểu tự
động ra 22
party
và tương lai tạo Open ruột và Open buộc
nó miễn phí mà mình thể dùng đấy nó xịn
chứ nhiều các bắt kịp chị ạ
cái giữa hai luôn này Cái này để kiểm
tra mình sẽ quy ước giống kiểu năm vẫn
giống kiểu i5 cho trạng thái thường là
nó liên quan đến ví dụ trạng thái đơn
hàng hai trạng thái bài đăng của tôi
đang làm ạ Ngoài việc là chiến giả lại
năm thì nó còn có cái hay cái việc cấu
hình cho cái việc là defoe mặc định là
gì này và nếu mà muốn thay đổi ở La sẽ
thức dậy là nếu mà thay đổi nghĩa là
đang từ trạng thái pending sang trạng
thái khác rỗi trạng thái tên Linh hiện
đang chờ sang trận hạ thấp dù đã duyệt
này thì thì sẽ phải từ nó chỉ cho phép
là từ trạng thái này sang trạng thái này
không cho phép là tự ví dụ dỗ từ trạng
thái past quay lại phê Linh được Nếu bạn
nhìn như này bạn sẽ hiểu ngay là Wedding
có thể chuyển thành bếp là đã thanh toán
hoặc bên định chuyển về fail nghe kiểu
đã lỗi chứ không có thêm tra Ừ từ phale
truyền lại pending hay gì đó thì Minh ở
đây mình sẽ xử lý mình sẽ thêm rất nhiều
lôgic vào trong cái này
ở hồ cốc này có vẻ hay này Ừ tôi sẽ
thương không biết được là reflect của
tôi có tự động đẩy thằng chẳng phải là
súng đây không tôi hết B tôi nhỉ đấy hay
phết nhỉ nghĩa làm chỉ là
sẽ để chấm phẩy ở dưới như thế này sau
đó thì mình sẽ copy kết nhau ngày tao
cũng kết chụp lòng cũng được Hay nhỉ
thế giới thư pháp
sẽ không lo dụ Giả sử do sửa ngày
đi học thì format của tôi tự động trở
lại
không mở trả thì tôi hồi chỉnh lại với
pho mát ít rồi Kiểu cái đấy hai điểm như
này mình sẽ thấy topic cột này như thế
này cho mình sửa lại theo ý mình về nha
nhậu sẽ không có bị ảnh hưởng gì cả
ơ hay phết I
ai Nếu đi không
nào nghe mà nhìn trong ngày 2 à
sau khi ở đây mày Ông thấy con fix kiểu
cấu hình ảnh như thế nhà em trẻ mình sẽ
chỉ cho thì cho cậu từ trạng thái này
nhờ sẵn Hải kia ngay từ trong xử lý ở
đây mà rất là hay và cái hai thứ hai đó
làm để ông thấy ở đây nó là màu rất là
sao nghĩa là ông hoàn toàn thể cấu hình
màu cho cái việc là khi mà ông in ra in
ra kết quả ví dụ là sửa đấy Nếu không
thấy ai kèo Nếu mà trạng thái làm pate
tất cả đã thanh toán thì sẽ chào cái màu
màu gì không ạ rất là hay luôn không ạ
đó em mấy ông thể từ gọi đến trạng thái
ở số gọi đến màu nó Vân tôi nghĩa là
nhìn thế này thôi thời gian mình hoàn
toàn để làm thêm được nhiều cái nữa
không phải một màu nhiều cái nữa nó
giống kỹ năng của mình là phiên bản nâng
cấp cao hơn với Nam rất nhiều Ngày hôm
nay từ việc ở mình sẽ con fix cấu hình
xe mà ngay từ trong cái năm này mình sẽ
cấu hình luôn là việc là từ trạng Hà nào
nhảy sang trạng thái cho phép ngược lại
đã xem hạn đấy có vài trạng thái mình sẽ
chỉ từ đây Sang kia thôi chẳng hại tiếp
theo là màu ở tiếp theo nữa là mình thể
gọi được thêm mình có thể tạo nhiều hạt
public phóng trình mà mình sẽ gọi được
thêm gọi đây được nghĩa từ status đấy có
thể gọi ra được rất nhiều với nữa Anh
rất là hay
nó kết hợp với việc cả Cái nó vẫn liên
quan đến ok hơn nó tưởng là cái Step 3
tầng stately này
đây nó vào tham gia của nó là đi ra và
tay này ra tôi nói Thấy tôi cũng chưa
xem hết được cái này nhưng mà Mấy ông
hoàn toàn thì xem tham khảo nhé Hãy tôi
vẫn để Linh ở đây cho bé ông béo xem lại
nhé
a tiếp theo kẻ tiện ích nữa Hôm trước
tôi mới dùng cái rĩa hay thực ra tôi
biết được trước rồi nha Mà hôm trước tôi
lại phải dùng lại để mà tôi ngồi tra bởi
vì hôm trước tôi muốn đóng góp cốt mấy
ông nói chung là mấy ông vừa rồi Thấy
mấy cái Pocket này ra chị nữa ông ạ Bây
giờ mấy ông mơ muốn là kiểu tên của mình
nằm trong cái danh sách đóng góp ngay về
giữa ngầu không ạ rất ngầu đấy thì thì
sự là kiểu Mình rất muốn đóng góp cốt
cho mấy cái kiểu trang ở nhà hôm trước
thì tôi muốn nữa à
Ừ tại hôm trước tôi có tôi có kiểu bình
luận ở trong này có cái Hạ
Hồi trước đã có người hỏi vẫn 2018 có
người hỏi là cái carbon này cái thư viện
carbon ấy là có thể trả về là kiểu là
buổi sáng buổi chiều buổi tối buổi đêm
20 đấy thì ông ấy thử cái ý tưởng mày là
hai vụ là ông ấy bảo là muốn kiểu Xin
chào buổi sáng 29 chào chiều có thứ ngờ
tôi nghĩ à Nếu mà Lý Tưởng hơn đấy thì
sẽ tạo ra một cái hàm là kiểu It it's
morning
afternoon kiểu như thế này thì nó hay
mình sẽ Tại sao tôi muốn làm thế bởi vì
nó như này
Ừ tôi muốn làm cái bài toán nó kiểu đây
trước mà tôi đã chữa cho một bạn thì ông
sẽ dễ hình dung hơn
đang ở nhà đây à
Ờ Ờ mình đi tên về cái view Teddy à
à à
vọng ai anh hiểu được hiểu
anh ở đây Tôi muốn nếu mếu để kỹ là hôm
trước tôi đã chia sẻ code ở trên discord
mà tôi muốn làm cái trạng thái Đặt lịch
nhà tôi mới nhìn thì là không giờ để
chọn thì nếu mà Mấy ông muốn lại sau
kiểu rất là cơ bản rất là cơ bản thì mới
ông có thể chơi theo kiểu này nó sẽ lách
of chân như thế này xong rồi à mình sẽ
Ford kiểu ngay rồi mình sẽ muốn cho lúc
đầu bắt đầu là từ
ờ ờ đổi thưởng đổi thưởng sẽ làm nhà thể
pp này
npp này tôi sẽ cho kiểu that our này sẽ
bằng các bon này ngay sau đó thì
áo kiểu Hòa
thì mình sẽ spread from Sam
ở nhà đi mình sẽ mặc định bắt đầu từ 9
giờ ngay
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ bắt đầu 9 giờ ngày
Follow for này
từ 9 giờ này
xong rồi à
mình sẽ có ae nào rồi đi
tiếng ạ
bao tiền máy tính
khi sex
nghe tiếng Anh à
A
topolo nhỏ hơn bằng nhỏ hơn Apple
ô ồ gợi ý ra một phát luôn à xin mãi
này Đây mình cứ cộng thêm 15 15 phút
thôi không phải 30 phút mình sẽ value
xảy ra như thế này ba lô này hơi sai thì
chị sẽ chị ra ngay tôi thử chạy thử cho
bé ông này
web môi giới này
mình sẽ có
ê ê
ông chủ nhật
Em biết là có cái à router a chưa
xe ô tô test hỏi test Angel đúng rồi
à à
khi hát xong lỗi này
ừ ừ
à À đúng rồi nhưng mà mình đang gọi về
out mình mặc định luôn đấy out Ok
bây không Trước mình sẽ đặt ạ Bây là
are you school Vậy à
thế này
em không có không lại những điều đó
anh Bởi vì cái me the way của anh luôn
chạy cái season xong mình lại cần lúc
kết tay là luôn gọi đến bảng ozo nên
thành ra vừa rồi nó hỏi bây giờ thôi nhà
em thấy không luôn á Không ở đây không
này chạy truy vấn của Midu quen ai mấy
ông thấy ra như thế này với 2 3 giờ thì
nó nhìn ra hiển thị ra ngoài nó không
sao nó không sao Nhưng là sự ông đương
nhiên à ông bắt đầu từ 8 giờ sửa ông làm
hai của rồi anh là kiểu làm kiểu dịch vụ
không bắt đầu từ 8 giờ xuống sẽ kết thúc
là kết thúc là 12 giờ Xong rồi đến 1
rưỡi ông ngoại một đặt tiếp chẳng hạn
thế 10 đến 1 rưỡi ông sẽ đạt đến tầm 5
giờ rưỡi chẳng hạn xô ngồi tầm mà 6 giờ
ở huyện Ba tiếp giờ xử thế thì ở thì thứ
nhất là nó lằng nhằng thứ hai nó còn
chia theo ca giống như tôi vừa nói đó là
k chữ cá sáng ca chiều và các tối thì
cái đoạn này xử lý nó sẽ kiểu có một ông
83 rồi xé rách nhỏ thường không ai làm
thế mà sẽ làm như thế nào chồng nhưng ai
có sang hôm trước tôi có bảo How's cái
gì đấy như này thì nó sẽ chia ra đương
nhiên là thứ vẫn cá nhân tôi rồi ta vẫn
thế hơi khó nhìn một tí
ở đây
Lê Ngọc giả sử ví dụ nha số ví dụ nhé
chọn khung rồi nhé
chọn cũng giờ kiểu này tôi tôi thấy thực
K hiển thị ở toàn bộ không giờ sẵn như
thế này nó sẽ đẹp hơn hiển thị ra kiểu
như này Đấy nghĩa cái này bạn chất nó là
gì nó khác với cái này điểm gì cái này
nó chỉ được radio
thì nó lại input radio nó sẽ chỉ ra kiểu
ngay chứ không phải là kiểu xà lách gót
chân mà Tôi thấy còn xịn hơn khi mà mình
có thể hiển thị ra là buổi sáng buổi
chiều và buổi tối kiểu kiểu như thế thì
đoạn này mình sẽ xử lý như sau đoạn này
vẫn chất là mình sẽ ra à
nhiều Nếu giả sử lại ví dụ là kiếm giờ
giờ hiện tại là mấy giờ Nếu mà chọn ngày
hôm nay thì phải ẩn giống như ngay cái
trang vừa rồi là nếu chọn ngày hôm nay
sẽ phải ẩn đi ẩn Đi kiểu dạng là ví dụ
là bây giờ là 8 giờ tối chẳng ạ thì thực
ra không được phép không được phép mà
chọn ngày hôm nay nữa là sửa ông muốn
quý đó gà trước một tiếng ông ông phải
đặt lịch trước một cái áo hạn mà 9 giờ
ông nghỉ rồi đấy ông sẽ không cho đặt
ngày hôm nay nữa đúng không ạ Cũng chỉ
cho đặt ngày mai sau đó thì mẹ
Ừ nếu là sử là tôi đang đặt vào lúc
đúng là tôi đang vào cái trang web của
ông vào lúc 8 giờ sáng thì ông chỉ cho
phép đạt từ 9 giờ đổ lên chưa ông không
ngờ cho phép bằng 8 giờ rằng ạ Nếu người
tôi không ạ Đấy anh nghĩa là mình sẽ
phải xử lý cái bài toán thì mình hiển
thị ra nó phù hợp tiếp theo Nếu mà giả
sử tôi vào vào buổi chiều thì tôi được
phép vào buổi sáng nay ông ạ nghe nó hơi
bị bất hợp lý không ạ sẽ chỉ hiển thị
phải ẩn tiếp theo là phải cộng thêm một
giờ so với giờ hiện tại nữa chẳng hạn
thế ít nhất là 2 3 giờ trên không có
trường hợp và kia à tôi tôi có thể đặt
ngay cái lịch mà cách đây của họ có 15
phút tiếp theo có nhiều trang bị như thế
nghĩa là kiểu mình đặt lịch 10 phút nữa
mình đặt cũng được nữa gửi thế thì cái
đặt lịch nó không mang tính chất gì cả
Đặt lịch cái bản chất là nó phải đặt à
đặt chỗ trước ít nhất là nhiều trang này
sẽ một tiếng nhiều trang là tận 1 ngày
đấy Không có trường hợp theo kiểu mình
còn mình ngủ ở nhà do mình đập cách tầm
10 15 phút đấy Xong rồi đến có chỗ ông
trường hợp thế đúng không ạ
Ừ thì không ai cái mày tao con người
người ta sẽ không xử lý do cho ông đó
ông ạ Đấy Thế nên là mình mình ở theo
theo tôi thì đó là mình sẽ phải xử lý để
bày toàn đấy nó khá là biệt một tí
chưa kể là bây giờ tôi như tôi đang nói
là tôi sẽ muốn lên chỉ ra thành Cắm mốc
các mốc dầu Ví dụ ở buổi sáng buổi chiều
buổi tối mà kết hợp nó là radio thì sẽ
xử lý như thế nào
Ừ ông ấy Ông ấy là hiểu được bài toán
tôi mà đúng không
tương tự Thế sao mình còn lại chọn này
được mình chọn nhà mình sẽ dụng ngày hôm
nay giống như tôi và bạn là thực ra là
hết ngày hôm nay rồi đấy
ví dụ là hết ngày hôm nay ở chỉ được đạp
đến 9 giờ nhưng mà rõ ràng bên 8:00 khóa
rồi hết ngày hôm nay rồi nghĩa là gần
như ngày hôm nay không phải bạc trắng ạ
Đấy sẽ phải xử lý như thế nào đấy tôi
Tôi chỉ nói hình dung bài toán đây nhá
hình dung bài toán thôi mấy ông có thể
chưa biết làm nhưng mà ông Ít ra cũng
phải hiểu được cái loại Toán đúng không
Mấy ông không hiểu thì người đó là sao
được không ạ cũng phải hiểu được và thực
sự là trải nghiệm người dùng cần nên như
thế nào đúng không ạ Không đi trường hợp
và người dùng đặt rồi xong rồi dùng đến
không Rồi bảo là anh ơi cái đặt thế
không được thế số người cãi nhau giữa vị
buồn cười không ạ đây thứ nhất thứ hai
đó là là ẩn đi Vân để người dùng đỡ phải
ngồi kéo xuống ngồi chọn cho nó đúng
không ạ Đấy nếu mày nhìn thì đã quá
nhiều người dùng sẽ bị đau mắt đúng ạ và
quá nhiều người dùng sẽ bị Mơ Hồ về dùng
sẽ không nhớ được ta thử mấy giờ mấy giờ
hướng cho nên là hiển thị ra sao cho đầy
đủ thông tin là một chuyện nhưng mà cũng
phải lược bớt thông tin nữa nếu mà giờ
sửa nó kiểu quá giờ cái hay vân vân ẩn
đi cũng được hoặc cả kiểu giống như cái
trang kia sẽ kiểu bôi màu ghi không được
phép đặt hàng ạ người dùng dễ hiểu là à
có khung giờ đấy nhưng mà quá rồi không
được phép Đạt người dùng sẽ nhìn cái
hiểu ngay đúng chưa ạ ấy thì mình sẽ làm
như thế nào
cho nó hiểu đoạn đấy không ạ
anh nói thế ngoài khối trước tôi thấy có
nhiều cách lag lắm một khi mà đã hiển
thị là không giờ rồi Tôi thích thì tôi
thể kéo sửa input thì ngồi sửa lại giờ
vẫn muốn đặt và đôi khi nó không vai tết
ở Bắc em thì vẫn Đạt thành công nó hơi
bị buồn cười à
ý nghĩa của mày ông làm xử lý file chưa
đủ nóng lạnh mấy ông vẫn phải sửa các em
nhé nếu không phải ba đến đoạn bắt lên
luôn và đấy bác lên file thì đế giao
diện người dùng để trải nghiệm người
dùng còn bác em mới thực sự cái thứ mình
lưu vào và Cái đấy là cái thứ mình sẽ
làm được không ạ ra sửa ra ở phân đen có
thể hiện thị sai nhờ bác em nó sẽ thông
báo về là bạn đã đặt sai thì còn chấp
nhận được còn hơn là người dùng
file hiển thị đúng nhưng mà người dùng
cố điển sai rồi ngồi bác em vẫn báo
thành công thì lúc đấy kiện ai đúng rồi
Chỉ Kiện Ông ơi ông người cốt mà
vì vậy có tiền thì khách hàng sẽ hiểu rõ
ràng mày gửi mail tao kiểu tao được phép
đặt tờ này mà cứ thử thử nó về chẳng
biết cái này
tôi muốn là giả sử Nếu thế gần như hot
cốt luôn là mình sẽ là một là mình sẽ
phát từ con fix ra thường là có thể chơi
trò đoán thử con viết ra để lấy khung
giờ làm việc nhưng mà giả sử ông thể quy
ước luôn thường như thế cũng từ ví dụ 8
giờ 12 giờ nó kiểu cố định ấy thì mình
sẽ làm nha à
thôi à
lấy thời gian hiện tại đi
ở
đây người thời gian hiện tại sau đó thì
mình sẽ kiểm tra xem là ít
thế nào
anh lớn hơn 12
anh đọc nó tiền gì Ờ lợn
Ừ vậy thôi nha mày
à Có sao mày không nhỉ
đề nghị luật hát ngày đi
ăn Tết
ở đền a h
thế nào
anh lớn hơn à
à à
lý một tí
anh lớn hơn 8
Ừ tớ lên bằng 8
anh em
Khi nào nhỏ hơn bằng 12 đó
vì sao mình sẽ dứt ở đây như này
Ừ mình bất hạnh này vào đây
em ở nhà à
à à
em không có thằng nào cả lũ ngoại tiếp
theo
anh ở đây sẽ là nhau ít
ô
ồ heo cái gì nào
anh nghe này Ừ thì mình sẽ
tĩnh nha một lớn hơn 8 này
anh lớn hơn 8
chị sẽ hiển thị già
là một tí Ờ
ý
nghĩa buổi sáng khi mà
tham gia sửa khi mà
một mình à
sau khi mà giờ hiện tại
em chưa quá cái giờ này
sau khi mình sẽ hiển thị ở đúng không
Chưa quá Giờ này mình sẽ bị
a tiếp theo là nếu mà
anh nghe này nó hơi mệt
U15 thì mình sẽ hiển thị thêm đây là sự
đây sẽ à morning
em buổi sáng
À không có gì cả ngọn cho copy cái đoạn
này tiếp
em ngày 8 giờ cộng 14 cái này sẽ là à
ừ ừ
mình sẽ là 13 giờ này
a cộng 4 tiếng này
13 giờ cộng 4 17 giờ 5 giờ chiều đóng
ngoặc cái sẽ afternoon là buổi chiều
kể cho nghe đi
em tắt có gì đó sai sai
Ừ đợi tí đại thì có gì ở xa đấy
à à
Khi nào của tôi là 13 giờ
thế thôi nhỉ Đúng rồi Nếu mà trên mái
trên chiếc máy của mình thì nó là OTC
không tức à nó sẽ chửi 7 tiếng Ừ thì bây
giờ tôi đang à Ba rồi nhớ đấy trên máy
local mình thế thôi còn về sau mà ông có
thể ký được cộng 72 Vân sau Nhưng nói
chung là đại khái trên máy của tôi thì
bây giờ đang 1 giờ chiều - 7 tiếng đi mà
này ra là nó vẫn đang hợp lệ bình thường
không như thế đâu
like và tương tự Thế giờ xử ông có ca
tối nữa tôi cứ làm bạn 2k này trước đã
nhé ờ
ở đây giả sử là tôi sẽ thay thế nào này
giả sử tôi thay thế nào là một cái giờ
khác ví dụ là sử ông đặt từ lúc bà giờ
sử là một giờ sáng ông tự nhiên ông rảnh
ông kiểu một lên đặt cái gì đó cũng sẽ
hiển thị ra nhà Ok không ạ
thế này
ông sẽ chọn là Nhưng mà như này ông vừa
thấy thứ nhất là ấm chọn cái này nó sẽ
có thể chọn được cái này nó trông hơi bị
buồn cười cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là như
tôi bảo nên hiển thị được cậu Rio nó sẽ
hợp lý hơn thì tôi sẽ sửa cái này radio
sẽ là
vẫn là bọc phòng vòng là false mình sẽ
bị kiểu Rio nó sẽ đẹp hơn rất nhiều và
ổn hơn mình sẽ inbox như ai
hay là radio là như này mà mình sẽ thì
ra kiểu ngày
này nhá mà mình sẽ phải còn lên cho nó
lên thì mình chỉ có đặt lên trùng là con
nhờ xỉn rồi chị sẽ đặt nê mà kiểu à à
a booking
khi tham hả
ở thời gian đặt phòng nóng lạnh
em xóa đi
là à
định nó xuống dòng ngang kiểu ba cái đồ
xuống dòng kiểu thế
sẽ có lây bồ ôm trọn cái lên trên thì
khi mà Kiều mình bấm vào cái này sẽ tự
động thích nó đó và tương tự Thế mình sẽ
copy ở đây
à à
từ những sợi Kiều chọn kiểu ngày ok chị
ạ
Ừ ok chưa đấy
Ừ nếu mà ông muốn làm thử giao diện đẹp
hơn thì thì ông sửa lại giao diện nhé
Còn tôi là mới còn chỉ cơ bản này thôi
để cho béo hình dung hiểu được là là xử
lý nó sẽ có thể như nào ạ
Ê mày ông còn phải chọn cái này con
đương nhiên là phải đi kèm với việc chọn
ngày nữa Chọn ngày thì sẽ phải ẩn đi
những cái mà tôi vừa anh nói thì có bài
toán nó sẽ phức tạp hơn một tí nhưng mà
nhưng mà cách giải quyết nó sẽ như thế
này nó kiểu hiển thị Kiến lịch thì thị
kiểu khung rồi chọn vân vân vân là cái
nên có giống bằng nữa kiểu cho nó đệt
kín
thứ ngày
ở đáy từ 8 giờ 12 giờ hiểu thứ là sự thế
rồi mấy ông thích thì kiểm tra thêm một
vài điều kiện nữa là sử là như vậy tôi
bảo là kiểu làm mấy ông kiểm tra là cái
thời gian hiện tại này
như thường lệ thế nào nhà chẳng
nào nha
ở ngay
Chị H để lấy ra được rồi
anh không bị báo lỗi thịt gà ngoạn ngờ
tiếp theo mình sẽ kiểm tra giờ sự là
mình bắt đầu mồi kiểm tra ít
xe tải nhạc tôi sẽ kiểm tra ngay cho
mình xem
Em sợ anh em tôi đã nhìn dễ nhìn này cho
mình sẽ có một cái
có nên dùng copy nữa không nó sẽ cộng là
cái rồi thật đấy à á
ví dụ là cộng nhà
mà lớn hơn
những kẻ này đây disable nói chuẩn luôn
i live I
ừ ừ
ê ê
à à
Ê mày bị đi xe bồn nghỉ
không hiển thị gì nhỉ
thế nào để tối thượng
Em có nhớ có D ở đây được
mình quên ở dưới này thế này rồi tôi lỗi
tôi
ở buổi tối
em có disable 200 thích là được sinh
nhật nó hiển thị ra nhưng không cho tích
tưởng như thế nhà ông vẫn muốn hiển thị
ra ra sự đấy Ông vẫn muốn hiển thị ra
thì ông sẽ làm ngay nhưng không cho tích
làm để hiểu là ừ mày không được phép đặt
quá thời gian này nhiều thứ còn thời
gian này được phép bật
ý nghĩa là đấy một tiếng nữa bởi vì bây
giờ tôi đang mặc định ở một giờ rưỡi
hoặc một đái ra tại trang không được cái
đoạn Nốt này đúng 45 này cho phép đặt ở
Ok chưa
em có cộng thêm một tiếng không được
phép đặt cái kiểu như thế
quá rồi mà là sử là như thế Ok chưa nghỉ
ngày không hiểu Dạo này mà không đấy thì
đây cách xử lý ở Portland còn bác e Nếu
như ông sẽ phải xử lý thêm một vài vài
biết các tướng suối nữa
Ê mày không có thắc mắc gì bạn nào nhỉ
khi đôi khi ở Tôi thấy mấy ông chậm nữa
Anh không biết là mình đang có dậy khó
quá Hay như thế nào sang thấy nhận xét
gì Em dậy chưa dậy đâu nha
chứ không là không gì không ông trả lời
không cho cái câu gì Tôi hỏi nhiều câu
lắm
anh hả
chia sẻ này Ví dụ ở cái này khá hay thế
hôm trước cả hai nó là Kiều có có nhóm
hiện tại là đang đang làm theo cậu là
chấm công ấy thì đôi khi là phải phải
cấu hình là ngày nào được phép nghỉ là
ngày ngày lễ hay cái gì đó
kết hợp việc là ngày nào vẫn được tính
lại đi làm với Vân thả thế này làm thêm
này ngày nghỉ này hãy các sự thứ mặc
định nó sẽ lấy ngày nghỉ của quốc gia
nào lại rất xịn sau đó thì thêm những
cái ngày nào nữa vì mình và cách viết
thì nó sẽ ra 01 và ghi cụ thể thời gian
hai ghi kiểu cụ thể kiểu như nay rất xịn
Nếu mà ngày hôm nay là thứ mấy thì ngày
tiếp theo thứ mấy vân ở tại sôi con này
đặc biệt nữa rất nhiều Các chị ai là cái
hay ở đây À nó hỗ trợ rất nhiều quốc gia
Đây và trong đó có Việt Nam rồi một tội
Lúc mà tôi xem cái Việt Nam thì thực là
nó hơi bị ít
con gà về các bà thì đúng là mình cũng
không cụ thể mới cái ngày kia lắm mấy
ngày tính nghỉ lễ hoàn toàn nhé
cho mình cái ngày đấy ở đâu Tôi không sợ
mưa
anh bấm thương nhớ không Đấy là tôi muốn
xem cái
mỹ nhân Việt Nam
30 tháng 04 mùng 01 tháng 05 mùng 2
tháng 9 này kiểu nhà thôi cũng chưa có
thêm một cái ngày thì đó nữa mấy ngày
quốc gia cũng ngày quốc gia nhưng mà
không không Tí nhà này được nghỉ sẽ
không tính vào trong đấy nhưng tính là
mình đi làm hơn nhiều nếu uống thử xem
cái á của bên Mỹ bạn như này us nhá á
National là quốc gia Nga không phải cho
khu vực nhé Ai nó còn có thêm cả ngày gì
đó Vân Vân Những Ngày Được nghỉ hãy trở
như thế
cho anh cái tin này Smart là thứ mình đi
từ ta có có những cái ngày đấy nhưng mà
không tính ở được nghỉ không được tính ở
Bình Dương đi đây cái kẹo thế
anh có thể để mày ông tham khảo Ok ạ Hôm
nay không có nhóm mà cần chữa gì à
Ừ đúng rồi nghỉ Tết nó hơi bị khó bởi vì
À đúng rồi Tôi đang định cập thì nó là
còn liên quan đến âm lịch Còn cái này nó
tính ở dương lịch nên thành ra nó mới
tính khó nhớ bị buồn cười là điểm mà tôi
thấy là cái ví dụ gần nhất với mình là
Trung Quốc mình cũng thừa hưởng khá
ngược kiểu lịch các thứ thứ Bình chung
mà ngay từ cái á
ở ngay từ cái đây tết đấy nó từ chung
thôi Gì à xe Na nhé
Ừ tí nó lại có thêm một vài ngày nữa
không biết bên này có nghĩa không kiểu
Kiều Mỹ cái kiểu
Anh Ở Đây Rồi sang đi này
Âm Nhạc
A
Pink flexible này
có ngon không biết rồi Con anh cỡ thế
này chứng minh là lễ
lễ thánh Minh à Nhớ hôm trước tôi chả
như thế
hình ảnh như thế ra mấy ông thích đóng
góp vào cái bắt ít này đây thôi của mấy
ông ấy sẽ sang bên sylas copy vài cái về
sau khi sâu vào bên này sửa cách để mà
Mấy ông đóng góp một cái gì đó là mấy
ông luôn Fox sport về cho mấy ông sữa
trong file mày ông xong nó cũng tạm
full.web cái kiểu thế
khi nghe xong
sau
khi mà sẵn hiện xong thì Tên của ông sẽ
được nằm trong cái danh sách là những
người đóng góp kiểu ngay nhoay nhoáy lắm
Thôi tôi từng đóng góp Chọn từng đóng
góp được một vài cái
anh cũng kiểu có cái gì đó mà chưa Tôi
nhớ tôi khoe sự đóng góp cái gì nhé Anh
sẽ lại khóc
ừ ừ
tạo ra các món ăn
à
Cậu sẽ tách dữ liệu để tạo ra các món ăn
kiểu đây
mình chỉ ngồi đóng góp về phiên bản
tiếng Việt thôi là còn thêm cái gì nhỉ
Đấy Tôi làm thêm cả vụ
em hỗ trợ cái provider của bên A tăng
số siêu ô
à à socio pro xi saliva Rider cho thằng
á led
Ừ
tôi Hồi đấy tôi Cậu ngồi mò thằng Credit
Xong rồi mãi nhận ra có cái thằng thư
viện số cli nó hỗ trợ ừ thằng led ít lâu
rồi này nhưng mà
muốn xem tài liệu nó đây nó hỗ trợ cái
đít lâu rồi
ở đền nhiều phải trưởng luôn ai
ra nó chả phải thiếu thông tin họ bản
chất nhé lúc nào ở Lúc mà tôi chỉ góp ý
ông này Peter về mỗi ID ạ cậu không có
nickname không Avatar luôn đấy các thử
thử vì về cơ bản thì cái mạng xã hội
reddit nó muốn người dùng gần như được
ẩn danh để mà thể đăng mọi thứ thoải mái
Nhưng mà thực tế và vẫn trả về những cái
chưa ngày mỗi tội hơi dị một tí thôi
nghe tôi có đóng góp vào đây ạ
cô gái có tôi này nó sửa này ngon mít
sữa đâu rồi
anh lấy tên về chứ không phải là mỗi
nickname đâu đấy cả tên về nếu có đấy
thế này ngồi sữa nick name được Ừ
nickname của da cũng được là cái kẹo kẹo
nhé
ý nghĩa lấy tên kiểu Display is your
name is ngày kiểu hình
a
baby Spider Man
âm thanh ở chung nhà nhớ tôi sẽ cả vụ
Avatar
có cửa sử dụng cao ta rồi
nhấn đại khái thế Tự nhiên mình đóng góp
được vào
Ừ nó cũng bé bé thôi cho mà thấy đóng
góp được cái gì đó hay có tên mình là
mang danh sách kiểu người không có mình
thì vui rồi
mày để tôi xem còn cái gì có thể mới nói
đó ngoài vẫn tương tự vẫn là cái booking
á Tôi sẽ ngồi chữa cho mấy ông về cái vụ
là bờ Hiển thị ra được cái
Nghe danh sách nó như thế nào ở Thủ ăn
cho béo hình dung bài toán
là xe nào vẫn còn vé này hay là hay là
bác sĩ nào vẫn còn trống lịch nhiều
không thì mình sẽ có bài toán là như này
sẽ Doctor đúng chứ ai đi này nêm này
đúng không
Sao nó đây là mình sẽ là booking này à
thì mình sẽ có ai đi
Doctor ID này rồi
Tết này kiểu ngay khi
Ừ
nó còn thêm cả với dụng là
Tab mà Anh nhớ là sự thế nếu muốn đặt
lịch theo cả lọc phòng khám tư tư nhân
nhà cậu là đặt lịch phỏng Đặt lịch khám
cậu là mấy giờ mấy giờ đấy thì cái xử lý
về toán ở đây nó sẽ như sau đó là
giả sự khi mà người dùng nên đặt và
người dùng chọn cụ thể bác sĩ anh theo
kiểu là liên quan đến cả chuyên khoa Bác
sĩ nữa nó còn lằng nhằng hơn mà còn
chuyên khoa Bác sĩ nữa cơ nhưng tôi cứ
tạm bỏ bụi đi làm kiểu đơn giản thì sẽ
là chọn bác sĩ để sau đó thì chọn ngày
ngồi chọn khung được chọn khung giờ cả
như thế thì ai chọn là k hiểu thế
à Có nghĩa là ca hoặc cả nước là sự chọn
theo tag ham thì được phải toàn khó hơn
một tí giờ tôi cứ thử giải quyết thì
hiểu bài toán khó đi một này sĩ Trang
này chẳng hạn từ tao chuyến
dụng idea một này một này do ngày 01 này
không ạ Rồi tắt đến that ha mà dụ là
kiểu 9 giờ ngày đối ngoại đấy tiếp theo
là thì nếu mà kiểu như thế này nhá thì
mới ông phải hình dung
ra sự giả sử tô cũ mặc định quy ước mặc
định quy ước là một lần khám sẽ là mất 2
tiếng trở lại thì thì mới ông sẽ hình
dung được là Ok nếu thế đi bơ tôi thử
hỏi mấy ông thì trả lời nhé Anh có 19
đâu Ở đây Tôi tin là chắc là cùng ngắm
mà có mỗi năm ông sẽ mua sách thôi à Bây
giờ tôi sợ tôi thử hỏi mà không trả lời
nhé á
khi bé ở Giang sử có cái bác sĩ như thế
này Mà tôi đặt lịch có lịch như này đúng
không ngày mùng 1 tháng 10 ngày mùng 01
tháng 01 được chứ
ờ ờ
em tôi đặt
và một lần khám thì dễ mất 2 tiếng để mà
khám xong Thế ở Giả sử Giả sử có một
người khác cũng đọc bác sĩ cha mày anh
vào lúc 8 giờ ngày hôm mùng 1 tháng 1
được hay không
từ 8:00
à mà vẫn là mùng 1 tháng 1 thì có được
hay không cũng là bác sĩ Cha
ex2 I
just the town 120
lý hay không Nghĩa là cùng nhờ bác sĩ
trang này có một bạn đọc từ lúc 9 giờ
rồi sao các bạn tiếp theo Đạt vào lúc 8
giờ làm là mình sẽ làm hai tiếng thôi rõ
một ca khám là hai tiếng đấy thì có được
đặt là x2 là hai là v320
không
Ừ
ông kia chọn có
Ừ ok
không
Ừ đúng rồi 8 giờ làm đến 10 giờ trùng
lúc 9 giờ đúng không
hay là cậu sắp xếp bạn lịch cái đấy tính
sau mình đang làm cái cẩu bài toán đơn
giản làm bài toán đơn giản triệu đã
nhiều nơi sẽ kiểu là sẽ gọi điện lại nó
vẫn sẽ cho đặt xong rồi có thể gọi điện
lại cho cho khách hàng để mà yêu cầu đổi
bác sĩ các theo thứ cái vụ đấy thì nó sẽ
giải quyết sau còn đang nói theo cả làm
bài toán đơn giản thôi là là mình sẽ vai
để kiểm tra để mà nó không bị trùng thì
cái này mấy ông thấy có chung với không
Nếu không sẽ thấy có nhỏ nhưng chung lúc
nào và tại sao nó chung để vợ Vân không
ạ thì bạn kia vừa trả lời thì làm từ 8
giờ làm làm 8 giờ đến 10 giờ sẽ bị trùng
lúc 9 giờ đúng ạ
a table
bây giờ thì bên mình sẽ thay lại
không Thế vào tôi đặt từ 10 giờ thì có
chung với khó
thì nó vẫn không sao cả kể cả ông đọc
một lốc thì ông vẫn in sốt vào trong
database vẫn theo lần lượt thôi và ông
Khi mà thằng nào Insert sau Thay đổi cái
bấm cùng lúc đi chăng nữa nó vẫn tính
quá à Thằng này xuất trước rồi Cả ngày
mấy xấu sau này nhá và khoáng rất sau
vẫn sẽ phải luôn kiểm tra là đã tồn tại
thằng chưa Không vẫn ở luôn kiểm tra ông
cốt đoạn vides ông vẫn phải luôn kiểm
tra chứ
Ừ Thì bài toán ở đây không Trước tôi có
vẽ cho bạn đấy thì phải dễ hình dung nếu
làm theo kiểu bài toán kiểu nhà nha
Thì thì ông sẽ làm được này 11 mà ông
lưu lại hẳn men and time cho nó dễ thấy
ông phải kiểm tra nó dễ thôi hai thì ông
sẽ hiểu ngay sự là đây có đặt lúc 9 giờ
đúng chứ sẽ 9 giờ 30 đến 10 giờ đúng chứ
anh đúng không Thì nếu mà khách hàng bật
từ 8 giờ không được 8 giờ này đến họ
à À quên quên đây 11 giờ nhỉ Ra làm đến
11 giờ đúng không bao giờ này
Ừ thì nếu là sử khách hàng đặt từ 8 giờ
thì họ sẽ không
em không nạp được không ạ
ví dụ chứ gì tương tự Thế ra đạt từ 10
giờ hoặc 10:15 chẳng hạn cho 10:15 này
a15
a cho đến 12 giờ 15 cũng không được đúng
trước tại sao
ở buổi rõ ràng là nó đã chạm vào cái
thằng trước đó Nó nằm trong khung của
mấy tháng trước đó như này rồi Nếu Để ý
kỹ không ạ Thế nếu là giả sử mà khách
hàng đặt trong cái khung giờ là từ 12
giờ đã sửa 12 giờ vẫn làm nhé đến 14 giờ
có được đàn ông có đúng không tương tự
Thế thứ 7 giờ sáng là sử khách hàng bạc
từ 7 giờ sáng đến 9 giờ được phép không
vẫn có đúng không Tức là sao nghĩa là
nghe thấy câu truy vấn của ông xử lý cho
đoạn này đó là ông sẽ bị kiểm tra là cái
Ừ cái giờ giờ khách hàng
Ý là mình sẽ chỉ Nếu giả sử mình chỉ lưu
mỗi giờ khách hàng đặt đâu nhá Cho mình
đặt đầu tiên là mình sẽ lưu là chín ở
đúng chứ mình sẽ cộng thêm 2 giờ để
thành 11 giờ đúng không là vào khách
hàng đầu này sẽ kết thúc đúng chứ sau đó
ý nghĩa là khách hàng đầu đạt thì hiển
nhiên thành công rồi nhưng khách hàng
tiếp theo đặt đấy thì mình sẽ kiểm tra
là cái giờ kết thúc của người ta như thế
này và cho dù người ta vẫn bạc và 8 giờ
thôi nhưng mình biết thừa rồi Kết thúc
của họ sẽ là mười rồi mình sẽ kiểm tra
10 giờ này có có nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng so
với 9 giờ 20
ảnh Đức đương nhiên là mười rồi nó sẽ
không nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng Sau 9 giờ đúng
không ạ thì không được phép bạn còn 9
giờ như này hoặc thậm chí là từ 6 giờ
đến 8 giờ em ạ từ 6 giờ đến 8 giờ
Ừ thì được phép đặt bởi vì rõ ràng là 8
giờ rồi Kết thúc người ra nhỏ hơn so với
cái chính nhỏ hơn so với 9 giờ xin mình
đưa phép đặt đấy tương tự Thế thì ngược
lại mình sẽ còn kiểm tra thêm là Nếu giả
sử không thỏa mãn điều kiện bên này cái
con thỏa mãn điều kiện bên này sao vẫn
được kiểm bên này là khi mà giờ bắt đầu
người ta lớn hơn hoặc bằng so với giờ
kết thúc của ông này đã ý nghĩa ông ấy
tập 12 giờ thì rõ hoa kết thúc rồi đúng
ạ Đấy như thế
ý tưởng tượng như thế phải cái cái cậu
Nếu mà cái dầu bắt đầu của ông mà
à mà còn nhỏ hơn so giờ kết thúc thì con
như ông sẽ không được phép đặt hãy chỉ
dẫn làm thôi Nếu tôi vẽ như này Tôi hi
vọng và mấy ông cũng hình dung được na
ná Cái này hỗ trợ học toán rồi mà
Anh nhớ còn gì Nhưng tôi nhìn nhìn đoạn
vẽ kiểu này tôi nhớ nó toát lên cấp 12
cấp 2 thì gì đó đấy nhưng đại khái nói
như thế nếu tôi lại sửa xử lý cái bài
toán này cho mấy ông cho mấy ông dễ hình
dung nhé
tỏa nào để tôi không học giỏi hạn không
học giỏi mình cái thứ toán lắm Ở không
để ý mấy cái đấy nhớ mấy ông Hiệp mấy
ông hiểu được cái heo mày không hiểu
được bài toán không quan trọng nếu hiểu
được bài toán này ông hiểu được cái này
không ạ ấy còn về cốt hay các thử thì
cái cái đấy Nếu chưa biết thì mày không
có thể còn là thì tôi chỉ được chứ còn
ngay cái việc mấy ông mà còn chưa hiểu
được mình phải làm cái gì thì
đi tìm mấy ông khó khó hình dung được
không ạ
Ừ đúng chứ mày không hiểu được cái thực
ra mình cần phải xử lý cái gì đúng không
thì bảo tôi chỉ hướng dẫn mình không
phải cốt là có nhiều mấy ông biết cốt là
không biết làm đồ án thôi đúng ạ Đâu án
của ông cùng mấy ông khó à chủ yếu vẫn
là liên quan đến lịch kiểu như ai thằng
quan đến nghiệp vụ thứ thứ không ạ
mình sẽ à
đi tôi sẽ đào tạo bao tay có bác sĩ này
rồi có
Du lịch khám đúng không mặc định lúc nào
là bác sĩ sẽ hiển thị ra hết tất cả bác
sĩ để chọn mình sẽ cho chọn thời gian và
chọn ngày tao thứ thứ đấy chị sẽ mặc
định sẽ hiển thị toàn bộ dạng danh sách
bác sĩ Cảnh nó sẽ như thế nào
có ai Tôi sẽ có form e
số
tiền đó sẽ cho chọn thời gian đến này
phút
Hay là đấy à
khi nêm tết nhatrang ạ
cha mày sẽ
khi chọn không giờ
anh thôi Lỡ rồi bạn kia rồi sẽ copy cái
này sáng đây cảm thấy ghét
à à
em ở nhà à
ừ ừ
ngõ sẽ có than Đây Rồi anh xin lỗi
Em sống rồi à Cái này cũng bây giờ xuống
dòng đi
à à
ở trọ không giờ chọn kiểu dầu ngay tới
khuyên với ông là để mày ông in xuất rồi
trong đa bay thì mày ông lên thiên cả em
nữa hệ số giây nữa
Ừ vợ tôi sẽ
vì vậy môi giới việc làm à để tôi thử
xem nhé
cho tôi một tí
để
tui sẽ có ghé web học viện thì tôi test
đi
Em thích dùng cái web mạnh hơn
cái tao bây là test mày nghỉ
sẽ chỉ làm việc với tao về test đấy thôi
ck này
Anh em mua rồi á thì ra tôi không muốn
cốt vào trong này phải lắm để tôi Tông
cái này sang cái pha khác đi đâu thì
được một tí sẽ có một cái hôm trước là
tôi tạm một cái à
Ừ tôi chưa Tạo một cái area that nhỉ
em biết cái này cái gì luôn
anh đúng không chúc con booking này
Ừ chắc mình làm Mochi người ở đúng không
chấp nhận booking rồi mà
à à BK thôi
ai ngờ tôi sẽ thay bằng à
Ừ tôi sẽ cho thêm chọn ngày ngọ
ai1
có
ai là Tết nên sẽ là hết hạn thế
Dong sẽ chọn
3:00
hình ảnh như này copy cái đoạn chọn thôi
xã học viện test
ở đâu tơ thằng hai ta à ông ngoại test
booking
Ở Bắc Kinh
thì nó sẽ chọn khung giờ chậm nhai
Mẹ nó bây giờ mặc định mà
có ai Tôi sửa lại cái để mà ghét mình sẽ
truyền lên cái gì
thì mình truyền lên là nét Tết sẽ tăng
377 xịt mãi chưa
Em quá xinh luôn
cho hàm Hán sọc
ở đó tiếp theo là mình là
khi chọn ngày rồi này rồi hết được chỉ
cần hai thôi mình sẽ chuyên lên là Tết
này
nhà hàng ngày xong à
tượng nhé à
mình không xem
ở lại mặc định là tôi đã chuyên đất
em chưa chọn mặc định mà mình sẽ có thể
lấy là lu là ngày hôm nay
anh
biết kiểu này được không mục tiêu thụ
ôtô không được mình sẽ là ý
if you and day nghe được à
thì mình sẽ mắc định là truyền lên ngày
hôm nay mấy giờ này sao nên là rồi như
thế này mình sẽ
mình sẽ lấy đết đối ngoại mình sẽ lấy
hết mà mình sẽ lời Tham đúng trước
vào đây database mình sẽ sửa lại đó mình
đổi cột này thành cột Dead này
Ừ nếu data pay của ngài tới sửa thành
luôn thành thiết tha mà ngay đây sữa
thành cột này sẽ tiết Hanh
ở tại xã deadtime
thế này nghe xong lại
Ừ mẹ lưu đại này đó thôi I ạ sau đó
xin lỗi Đúng rồi không Còn cái cột ship
này nữa mình sẽ là mình sẽ truyền cái A
biết ha bằng Tết
em ngồi với thằng này như thế này
Anh ở mình sẽ gọi đến ham chuẩn ngay
Ừ rồi đết ham à
cho anh chuyện này vào thế là xong hết
Xong rồi
mẹ con nhà mình đã xử lý được
ở các kiểu là những cơ thể
ở đó mặc định có 3 bác sĩ đúng không ạ
bây giờ sự là kiểu Bác mình chọn vào
khung giờ này
ở bên A
ở mỗi lần khi mà thằng à
I I I put mày
cập nhật lại cái kết Pasteur phía sau
à à
ừ ừ
anh vẫn được bạn giờ bác sĩ làm ông ạ
Bây giờ sửa tôi sẽ cho là với cái ngày
ngày này không ạ ở bụi cá rô này bác sĩ
Long sẽ bật
a cho hạ thế mình sẽ là
13 giờ này
gì đấy
Ừ thì à
tất cả Tại sao Zalo nó bằng nhau này
Ừ đợi tí nhớ gì sai sai rồi
thứ ba lô bằng nhau thì sai đấy
e-blue
ở Tab Hour format
em hết
thêm là mình sẽ phải xe lactum nữa
sẽ lấy cái đầu tiên đấy gì gj Chết thật
tích
ở trên utrecht truy cập tại đây à
à à
Ừ nếu không thấy mặc định truyền đây là
13 là sai đấy không
không đấy thì không cần
Anh ở ok chưa ạ
đầu tiên giờ đầu tiên có thể chọn được
ngay từ đầu đi để để cho nó chuẩn đi để
thay vì mình chuyển mỗi cái chết ngay
thì tôi sẽ là
ờ ờ
I eat
à à
hội chọi trâu
đã nổi rồi có spam chưa
có nhớ cái Hàn có cái bếp ga
bộ đề kiểm tra cái lúp có quyền sử là gì
Blade
Ừ
đợi tí đợi đi
dù cho lúc
nhà nghèo ít ít
chỉ có Face thôi
đầu tiên thì sẽ
anh còn không thì ở mình sẽ là
à à
phụ trách phát bóng Chu này cho npp
nó hơi bị thủ công một tí à
Ừ
cái nhỉ
vì vậy Ý là không cho điện à
à à
ừ ừ
ở ngay
Ừ nó mà định sẽ được thích đâu
Em hãy sao mặc định sẽ truyền cái hàm số
e lên lấy ra như này
Em hãy thế được à
chỉ kiểm tra mỗi bài toán là kiểu dạng
là nó được đặt ở trong không giờ nói
không mà nó sẽ phải kiểm tra thêm bài
toán là là là cái bác sĩ này không phải
chống mỗi khung giờ này mà còn phải cộng
thêm + thêm ví dụ ở sử cộng thêm mà
trong trường hợp này đã 15 giờ đúng
không Đây 13 rồi đúng không Bây giờ xử
để cộng thêm 3 tiếng đấy nhá + thể 3
tiếng
à à
a + 3 tiếng lên thì tức là sao mấy ông
nhớ khi nghe không ạ nghĩa là thứ nhất à
cái giờ này sẽ phải nhỏ hơn bây giờ này
đúng trước hay là giờ bắt đầu ấy rồi Kết
thúc sẽ nhỏ hơn người bắt đầu vân vân
tôi hiện xử lý đoạn này như sau cách tôi
xử lý nó sẽ như thế này giống thư xem
nhé ờ ờ
rồi bắt đầu tôi sẽ gọi để rồi bắt đầu ở
ừ ừ
xe tải nhạc
à Mà giờ kết thúc
à à
em copy luôn lại cho copy để nó không +
thằng kia mình sẽ cộng thêm
hai ba tiếng
nhatrang ạ Giả sử muốn muốn cho quy ước
là ba là sử ông có thể ở đây là tôi
thường ai tạm cái con fix ở đây kiểu Nga
quay về rồi Đây
anh sữa ông thầy để đó là số phút thường
là nên để số phút cũng hay làm dụng là
là kiểu à
a number
à à
Ở Bắc Kinh Ngạc hạn One Piece One sheet
tên hay là một ca nó sẽ hiểu thật sự là
180 phút ngày để xe áp a minute của Doji
họ đến như này nó
Ừ anh có đi thăm start Tết hàng anh em
Ngay sau đó mình sẽ xử lý đoạn này như
nào chị sẽ weather đây mình tôi thường
anh sẽ làm là Wave
vào Woa chính ra đấy
ngoài đấy nó sẽ là đếch tham này
Ờ Ờ
mình cần là mình cần là cái giờ đầu tiên
mình kiểm tra là cái giờ kết thúc của nó
phải nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng bây giờ bắt đầu
đúng không ạ
không biết đấy
Cho xem nhạc
ở đây à
à à Không bằng giờ kết thúc chứ
em là đại Tí à
anh
như này
khi họ tiếp theo là
ý là cái cái thằng này cái thằng cái này
sẽ cái thời gian bắt đầu này sẽ cộng
thêm 3 tiếng
ý chính ra cậu lên 180 phút sau đó thì
so sánh nó với cái giờ bắt đầu đấy thì
cái việc đây mình sẽ là ác
Em à em
You
are my queo trắng
Em hãy đâu sẽ có cha hàm như này
chị sẽ là
đế táp xong rồi ông chuyên cái này vào
số ông phải sống inter vô như thế này
em có độ Israel Minute I
thế này đúng
Tôi
muốn xem truyện ở đây là đô la
Zip họ đến a number booking này Tâm
một ngày sẽ cần à lớn hơn hoặc bằng so
với bếp hàm start
mẹ
cho mày không xem dễ hình dung nhé
anh không thấy là cậu truy vấn của tôi
sẽ thành như này
đầu tiên thì à
xe Honda faze coledatetime nhìn như này
cũng sẽ hiểu là cái khác đấy phải thêm
cái dấu này để hiểu nó là hết ham nhé
về mặt tự nhiên thừa cái ở đây
có ai
Ê bà cái này mặc định mình sẽ đổi là cái
á hiểu ngay tại sao mấy ông lại thấy có
cái kiểu dạng như này nó khái niệm mà để
tránh apples sân Nó là kiểu Papa
para mấy ông thích kiểu không thể chuyển
thẳng vào đây cũng được với nghĩa chuyển
hàng vào không sao vì vừa các bạn thì
ngày Nếu mà dịch ra lỗi thì nó cũng
không ảnh hưởng lắm
thì nó sẽ báo lỗi ngay cái đoạn đấy Dạo
này ông người truyền thông hiện ngay Tôi
thích truyền thô cái này cũng được
à à
ừ ừ
Lý Hải
bằng luôn này vào cái này phải em mới
đúng thì tôi sẽ vứt cái này vào trong
nhà
Huawei e
anh ở đây que như này rồi nhưng mà nó
vào đây là sai thì tôi sẽ phải quay ở
đây đúng
rồi lại face I
ừ ừ
để
Chị xem thử nha
anh em đầy đủ rồi đó
này
đây sẽ là
hôm nay thành đấu chửa
những ngày bố nhỉ
nếu mà cái nết ham của ông nằm trong
khoảng như thế này
em nằm trong khoảng như này
thì nó sẽ mất Bạn là bác sĩ Long 1 vì ở
rõ ràng là bác sĩ năm có ca xong rồi
không rồi đấy rồi đúng
ông chủ nhật
18:15 giờ này buồn cười
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí
ê ê
phải như này phải
lớn hơn tham Andy nhỉ Đấy nó bằng
comment
A và cái này sẽ là nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng
à à
từ nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng timestamp đây đây
đây đây tôi bị ngược Đấy
A và cách viết này Tôi nghĩa có khi
không chạy đâu một kìa kìa Hình như là
thiếu dấu nháy sẽ báo lỗi để ngôi nhưng
có khi là sample kia nó hay Còn nếu
không thì cũng sẽ phải thêm nháy rồi đây
ờ ờ
à à
ừ ừ
anh trai đâu mà
xin hãy
Anh đi vào này
ở đây à
du lịch thi trợ thính có nhiều sai sai
đấy
anh nghe đây Đúng rồi hay sao Thằng này
bị xuống dòng nhé
chồng tao nó Kệ vậy
Em tải phần này đó là long long như
người say đấy ạ
à à
thế này
anh
vẫn như cũ thôi là
học bằng
vậy à
từ nhỏ hơn Ngọc bằng
cài đặt lúc mệt 15 giờ này
nó
D3 phải không nằm trong về thăm này tự
thế thời gian bắt đầu của nó lớn hơn
hoặc bằng với thời gian à
khi kết thúc đồ ngon
ở
cái thời gian này nó không có Ừ nhưng mà
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
ở cấp 3 tiếng cái này cũng 3 tiếng nó
phải là
Ừ cái này cậu ba tiếng nó phải lớn hơn
này chứ nhỉ
vì thế bị ngược
anh đúng không
Em
có phải
lớn hơn hay nhỉ
Ừ tao đúng à đúng à
hay sai mà
này nha Mình cần lấy ra không đấy
từ ngày thỏa mãn nữa này không thỏa mãn
đúng không hay không thỏa mãn ngay chắc
chắn thỏa mãn luôn này đúng không ạ
nó sẽ là
à cậu nên sẽ 16 giờ
nhỉ À thằng ngày mặc định nó phải lớn
hơn như mình đang quay Note đây là phải
ngược lại nữa thằng này phải nhỏ hơn này
thằng này phải đây nhưng lãi đấy tôi nói
tôi
Ồ
vãi chưởng Vãi văn ngắn
Trưởng
một bác sĩ ngoại
bác sĩ Hạ Thị giờ khác nha
Hình như có gì đó sai sai rồi
anh alo 17 giờ
Ừ ừ nhớ gì đó xài rồi
à à
từ nhỏ hơn thời gian hiện tại thấy ông
đoạn này sai mà lại tôi thấy đoạn này
sai ý
sự phủ định phủ định của phủ định cho
việc làm nhằm vào bình tĩnh nhá và để
cho xe Mẹ Lưu dịch nhá Mình cần lấy
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi thế câu truy vấn
này của tôi phải là lấy ra
em lấy ra giờ mà phải vi phạm hiểu kiểu
là nằm trong cái khung này cơ chứ phải
nằm ngoài đúng rồi bờ quen lót mà
ông ngoại lấy ra
đây là tôi đang bị nhầm là lấy nó không
Giờ hợp lý nhưng thực ra tôi đang cần
lấy không Giờ vi phạm cơ thì tôi mới
quen not okei okei nghĩa là cần là bà
đấy á không Giờ vi phạm sẽ là cái
Ê thằng này sẽ phải nằm trong cái phạm
vi này hoặc xanh này phải nằm trong phạm
vi này
cùng nằm trong phạm vi này nhưng mà rõ
ràng là không quan tâm mới vị rõ ràng
chỉ cần một trong hai đã sai rồi Đấy
phải như thế cơ mà chưa
anh đợi tôi tế Nội thô lỗ Tôi hơi lăng
nhăng cờ
cả ngày nằm trong khung giờ vi phạm
không ạ Mình sẽ là que
Ừ ừ đúng rồi quay betwin thật à
à à
gì vậy Nó có gợi ý
thằng này phải nằm giữa cái đếch tham
ở nhà bị ngập nha à
có ai Tôi sẽ xử lý như sau này
Cho
hỏi chấm với thay thằng hỏi chấm nhé Nó
sẽ dễ hơn nó lại làm trước kia chị sẽ là
bit win a
thế này
anh ở đây sẽ là
khi tham Facetime cái phone này nó bị
kiểu thêm cái dấu hai nó thêm xấu quá à
anh với sửa lại cái phong người Pháp
ờ ờ Sơn tinh này
chưởng
Ừ cái monalisa này
gì đấy
bộ phim này không sao
anh nghe cái bên này tự nhiên nó bị lỗi
nếu để trong túi nhái
ý nghĩa
anh này vẫn không sao vậy nhỉ Sao thằng
Nếu thế thằng giấy tờ bị ngu à
chết
anh
em thấy thêm vào nhà em lại Trưởng
anh em
ông kể
anh thợ hồ ok rồi này
I will blow tiếp
ở đây xem step này
cho tôi thử chạy thôi lại mày không xem
nhé
ờ ờ nhỉ
a How do ở đây
Bí thư Đoàn Hải Phát
bạn kia Xóa Thằng này thì chả trai đã
nha
Ừ
sáng nay đi này
thế này
à à
em xem cái gì
ăn
cơm khởi động ở đó
anh bình tĩnh
- 16 giờ 19 giờ
nhỉ
ừ ừ
16:19 giờ ở đâu
Ừ ừ đúng rồi làm sao phải đi này đúng
a
16:01 đi
anh không nào cho hành vi ok rồi
17 giờ rất là nó sẽ không nằm trong phạm
vi này ok
khi được nhà bây giờ đúng rồi
cơ hội phát thì biết ngọn 16 giờ không
có bác sĩ Long nóng lạnh
i10
đã 6 giờ 15 có bác sĩ nào
- 16 giờ không bác sĩ Long Ok Chị nói
Anh mệt thế một cái đoạn này ngồi sửa đi
nhưng mà Xuka giải quyết được bài toán
này thì mấy ông ăn tiền rồi mấy ông thế
là xong rồi thì thôi gì khó đâu
vẫn thường ai thích cậu thêm số phải ở
trong cái mặt đằng sau Bill thêm cái gì
đó Hỏi chấm cái này hỏi chấm nó sẽ được
thay thế với cái này nhá ạ
ở thời tiết thì có khai báo biến kiểu
kia
Sửa đoạn này khác là ngạc Không ạ nhưng
mà
khi tôi ngồi sửa cái này tầm cứ cho Nãy
giờ thằng có tiền đi đồ án mấy ông cũng
sẽ chỉ quanh còn có mỗi có nhiều ông Đặt
lịch kỳ khó nhất một các bạn này thôi
thì tôi sẽ xử ở mình ông rồi ông ạ
Em hãy viết chỉ việc bấm Đặt lịch ở xong
ông ạ
em gà cũng được tùy vợ cậu thì ba tiếng
rồi ừ thì đương nhiên là mấy ông sẽ thêm
cả thời gian nghỉ giải lao Vân ra cũng
10 thực tế ngoài đời thì ông cũng không
cần phải nhất hết câu ký ở đâu vì gần
như là
em là người ta không tính hẳn vẫn một
giờ mà không hẳn là kiểu dạng là đúng 3
tiếng thì ông mới hiểu làm xong đâu Đúng
mày không có thể một lần bé ông nghỉ sớm
hơn Thuận chứ em đọc truyện Cối hơn thịt
thì cái người đến sau người ta sẽ đợi
một vài phút được mà Không sao cái lọ
không đến nỗi phải cắt cắt như thế
Em không hiểu ý tôi không nghĩ là ông
không cần phải ngồi tính toán cẩn thận
mình cả như thế trừ khi mà phải toàn Yêu
cầu phải khắc hẹp từng chính xác từng
phút một thì nó khác Còn đây À cái này
về cơ bản đặt lịch cái ông ông đấy nó có
đúng giờ ở đâu người ta không thể ngồi
căn chuẩn ông đúng năm giờ ông mới được
vào đúng không Ông đến sớm mà người ta
dọn rảnh thì ông được vào sớm đúng không
tương tự Thế là người sau người ta ông
đang làm ông đang nằm rồi chẳng lẽ tao
từng người ta đuổi ông ra Đủ 3 tiếng rồi
không có ngoài như thế không ạ vẫn thoải
mái
không đạt được trùng nữa tao đấy
Ừ nhưng mà
đúng họ biết quy thì nó sẽ hiểu nó sẽ
kiểu nó là bắt phải Khớp nó sẽ bị quy là
bằng mà nếu mà sự ra thế đi Nếu thế thì
mình sẽ đạt hết cả 15 mình sẽ cộng thêm
15 phút nữa được má thế này được mà
lắm Còn nếu với em cũng không muốn kiểm
tra BigWin em sẽ kiểu so sánh cả lớn hơn
Lớn hơn nhỏ hơn nữa đây là được thì nó
sẽ đỡ hơn
Ừ nếu mà cái này dây rồi mà À cái này
phút rồi mà Thì kiểu gì nó sẽ em sẽ lớn
hơn hoặc bằng ở đây cũng được tùy
gì đấy em sửa sửa lại còn anh thì anh
Nghĩa nó không ảnh hưởng lắm em chỉ cần
đổi 15 cái còn nhờ có Bác sĩ này là được
đúng không Nghĩa không ảnh hưởng là gì ở
đây cả
nào thêm là tùy ông đóng ngoặc với các
bạn tôi nghĩa thế này ổn một bộ hôm nay
chả cũng tương đối ơi không còn nhỏ mắt
sao mắc gì thì hiểu mình sẽ tạm kết thúc
rồi nha
đam À cái này cho ông ấy ông hiểu mà
không nghe tội 007 cốt lên đâu Đây là
mấy ông sẽ phải tự ngồi xem tham khảo để
làm lại đấy này từ sau một sữa con fix
gì sửa đây chỗ khác nó sẽ chạy khá hợp
lý hồi âm lưu lại ở trong sẽ sunfic gì
tùy ông OK nhá ngoài cho dừng lại đây
thôi
Xin chào béo nhỉ